-Mike Schur, who created
"The Good Place,"
and who you had
worked with before --
You worked with him on "Parks.
He had this idea
really laid out.
And I think he knew from the
beginning that this would not be
a show that would be on
for gratuity.
-Forever. He's like, "This sho
one day is gonna end."
And I was like, "Be optimistic."
[ Laughter ]
Yeah, he did.
He always had an idea of
how it was gonna end.
I don't think any of us foresa
it happening so quickly.
-Yep.
-But the reality is, you know,
is in television --
Most writers in television
you guys, like,
episode 17 through 21,
they're like, "It's fluff.
Just get us to the ending.
-Yeah.
-So I really like these
encapsulated seasons
where it's 12 or 13 episodes
It gets people to watch.
He figured out what the ending
should be
and he thought
we could draw it on foreve
and some people might taper of
'cause, you know, next episode
"Jason loses his shoes."
Like, you don't want to follow
that plot line.
But it's also
a little bit of a metaphor
about the human experience
is that it's over too soon
and it leaves you
wanting a lot more.
[ Audience aws ]
-And it will be very --
I'm excited to watch it,
but also we're going to then
live talk about it.
I'm gonna host a thing with yo
and the rest of the cast.
-I'm so thrilled
that you're doing that.
-It'll be a blast.
-All of us will be here.
We'll all be,
like, crazy weeping.
Especially D'Arcy.
Watch it if anything
for the way D'Arcy cries.
It's so cute.
[ Laughter ]
-One of the things --
because I have heard,
obviously people my age
love this show.
But I have heard that kids lov
this show because it talks about
a lot of things
that people don't know
how to talk to kids about,
things like death
and what happens
when a loved one moves on.
-Yeah.
-Is this something --
Have you started talking t
your kids about that yet?
-Yeah, we did have --
Well, yeah, actually.
We -- Our daughter when she wa
five said, "Am I gonna die?"
And we both -- like, the air got
sucked out of the room.
And we were like, "This is it.
What do we do?
There are so many roads.
Like, do we make up a story?
Do we say we don't know?
Do we say we know
and then actually not know?"
And we just said,
"Yes, you're gonna die."
And she went, "Ugh."
[ Laughter ]
And then we said,
"And we really don't know
what happens when you die.
You may just become flowers.
And she went..."Okay."
[ Laughter ]
And we were, like, so relieved
Because we did make a commitment
never to lie to them.
And that's, like, controversia
'cause we also --
They asked about Santa Claus
And I was like,
"I'm not gonna lie to you.
-He's dead.
[ Laughter ]
And we don't know --
He's flowers.
Now he's flowers.
But I think because of that,
our kids have adopted this ver
practical sense about the world.
And so, like, recently
their grandfather was dying.
And he's already passed,
but while he was dying,
my little girl was in the back
And she said when,
"So, when Papa dies,"
'cause we knew it was days
"Are we going to come
to Oregon with you?"
And I was like,
"Yeah, you'll come."
And she said, "Okay.
Do I need to bring my shovel
because I have a garden set.
[ Laughter ]
And I said, "Why would you pac
your shovel, honey?"
She goes,
"Well, I want to help bury him
Where do we do it?
The side of the house or..."
[ Laughter ]
Like, so practical,
and, like, wanted to help.
And then I had to explain to her
we -- you know,
we don't bury him
on the side of the house
because it's not legal, but --
[ Laughter ]
She genuinely wanted to,
like, bury her grandfather
And I thought, like, there's
something weirdly,
oddly beautiful about that
Like, she's a younger member o
the family contributing
to an older member's
peaceful passing on.
-Yes, there's a real
circle of life to that.
-Some people could say
she's a sociopath.
-Yes.
-I don't --
[ Laughter ]
I'm not going down that route.
-I think it would have bee
worth hearing
what she was saying
as she was throwing dirt on.
-Right, right, sure.
-That might have revealed, like,
a lot more than what
we're talking about now.
It is so wonderful
to have you here.
I'm going to see you tomorrow.
-Yes.
-I can't wait for that.
-I'm so happy.
-Thank you so much for letting
me be a part of that.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Kristen Bell, everybody.